[Music]
so and then she also uh commits elderly
abuse in this trailer yeah which is
awesome because I think it's about time
we take down the old people I'm getting
it away you know like just cuz they're
old doesn't mean we shouldn't hit them
once in a while regardless roll or not
listen if any of you guys work at a
hospice center just start punching them
when they should have a hand as their
captain marbles I'm not sure that's
werster sure that's a scroll scott it's
maybe she thinks the scroll and that's
gonna be like that's where she's
shooting out on the train hey reject
nation greg alba here John over here
Andrew over here so Andrew Gordon over
on the movie source channel and John
Humphrey here so we just did a reaction
to the Captain Marvel trailer obviously
the first time you watch something
there's a lot of excitement a lot of
enthusiasm there's things you're gonna
miss there's things you you're not gonna
grow time to really break down yeah we
mister Oh miss Road no didn't even touch
on Marvel like there was a there's
certain things were like we just don't
have time right now for the first video
we were like you know we'll just do
another video right afterwards so here's
that other video before doing that I
want to thank everyone who's been
joining our patreon page we've been
gotten a lot of patrons lately over
there we do TV show reactions for shows
like my hero academia attack on Titan
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood Gotham
Riverdale and Supernatural also do
weekly Q&A with that in mind before we
hop into this video I want to give a
patron the day shout out to a woman
named Rosa Parra she is like the lady
Stark of our channel and Rosa
I feel really bad still because there
was a live Schmoe town event very
recently for Collider videos of the El
Portal Theatre had no idea you were
there had no idea you run in her posts I
was I didn't check my social media to
like way after the event normally on
weekends I kind of avoid social media
throughout the day I felt terrible at
you and Cassandra were there but next
time I promise is any kind of event I'm
gonna check my notifications to see if
you're there we owe you a drink we owe
you dinner
we owe you a good time my friend a
really good time I love you my dear and
really sorry about that in a lot of ways
you are the captain marvel of our
channel too anywho let's get into this
all right you guys ready I'm ready let's
break this trailer down peeps do it
[Music]
okay so she's falling from the sky in
too long yeah I have to a blockbuster
that's a video store that used to have
these things called tapes video normally
I don't think the Marvel trailers give
away the openings of their films I
imagine this is the first 10 minutes I
don't think the exact opening shot this
has to be the first 10 min I mean when
we saw the Infinity war sure that I
thought all that Loki stuff was gonna be
in the first few minutes and sure enough
it was so maybe this is the first units
because later on and they're here when
Sam Jackson he's talking about alien
invasion Karkar a car crash all those
things some preliminary halves of her at
the very beginning it's like I imagine
that this is a later shop where there's
a spaceship in there and that must be
what Sam Jackson's referring to and all
this happening and she's in this suit
right now - yeah a Star Force - the Star
Force ooh yeah so this would be that
maybe we'll get like a smidge of action
right before she crashed lands or
something like that yeah I actually
wouldn't mind if they just hop right
into it no I think if you go straight
falling falling yeah kind of you know
yeah and then they kind of just received
it all with like flashbacks and stuff
like that yeah I guess weirdly and when
I watched his trailer back while I was
editing it I kind of got Man of Steel
but maybe potentially a little Deadpool
like hopping around within the past's
parts of the origin with also because
she's already gonna start the movie with
her powers and there's obviously gonna
be stuff that's already happened by the
time she gets here so maybe some of that
I mean other than that structural thing
I don't get a tonal thing at all not at
all no no structure yeah but in terms of
tonal it's like especially with you know
how it's working so she and her
superheroes is an incredibly charismatic
and then Superman didn't have that super
charisma that we did again matter
stealing well it's even the music kind
of seems a little Hans Zimmer esque that
I think about it and now cuz I really
like the music here and I feel like
Captain Marvel could have a standout
score from the Marvel films there are
some of the Man of Steel vibes but yeah
actually crashes into Blockbuster Video
which if you're born after the year I
don't know 2005 or something you're
probably like what the hell's a
Blockbuster Video
that you see on every single corner when
I was growing up oh yeah the most
expensive rentals you could have ever
thought over there yeah also the late
fees usually killed you too oh gosh and
blockbuster was expensive as [ __ ] not
surprised you're out of business
yeah they're so bright so you couldn't
out of the question
Odyssey video yeah but it's cool to see
the obviously something like a 90s that
aesthetic thing that you know just
throws you back into the 90s so it might
be nineties like the perfect way to go
it's the nineties there's you wanna
storytelling people
[Music]
[Music]
yes in a second
space invasion
it seems like in the first parts of this
movie Yoshi crash lands on the earth
she's not remembering her past at all it
even kind of seems like when she's
wearing that shield hat right mhm and
then she knows to use her thumbprint so
she can get access into shield is that
part of the beginning of the movie where
she's just kind of trusting her
instincts or she gets a quick flash that
you know maybe she had was had
experiments done here or something like
that before she left earth or maybe
someone just tells her to use her thumb
bridge and she's just like oh it works
you know I can definitely see there
being that element of them kind of
taking her in and kind of having to
explain some things don't even get her
caught back up kind of like yours oh
wait yeah it felt like a little bit of
that kind of callback like at the end of
the first Captain America when they're
slowly bringing him back yeah I know
because it's a lot to take in to just
say hey dude you've been frozen for say
I'm excited for this car chase man like
I hope that this is actually I'm gonna
feel because I'm gonna feel the 90s of
speed yeah cuz the last couple normal
movies have also had a good element of
like a mandala watch it had some pretty
cool car chases black panther that's a
night car chases and you know I
appreciate that from them I don't know
they never matched the intensity of the
Winter Soldier car case Nick do you know
what a greatest action sequences
[Music]
is he saying spaceship space invasion
big car chase and they had that shot
where the space invasion shot is right
my thought is that's probably the very
beginning of the movie that image that
we had right there and then big car
chase it seems like she's gonna go on I
can't tell if she's here on earth by
accident or she's on a mission because
she's on top of the subway station or
the train or whatever she's using her
powers which is a really awesome shot by
the way just that flip and then yeah you
got first look at some of that you know
a lot of people bring up Superman in
relation to Captain Marvel would
describe it like just how powerful she
is and that was a cool image to showcase
that but is it like a funny moment that
Marvel's hiding as a serious intense
moment you know she thinks something
weirds going on so she's using her
powers or is she here on a mission and
attacking someone you know going after a
threat I like how they're setting up
Nick Fury and I think he's been I mean
it's more of a bureaucrat you know
working in within shield but I think I
think Phil Coulson it's his first year
in fields I think Samuel Jackson's been
there yeah I'm not sure of the timeline
but I think he's been with shield a
little bit looking for something beyond
this something you know or supernatural
in that a big deal but I wonder if
they're even gonna mention Robert
Redford's character in any way just
getting me out gender Pearce seems like
there's a potential for a nice amount of
this movie to have them together you
know her and Sam Jackson I feel like
that could be really a cool combination
for a movie like this especially if they
do want to capture some of that like 90s
Top Gun sort of that line you're not
from around here it kind of feels a
little bit of that callback to the
Avengers when he says to Steve Rogers I
think he's describing like he says he's
not from around here it also seems like
shield at the point they're at is I mean
they're always being a secret
organization but they seem there are a
lot more underground at this point you
know you get a lot of like desert shots
and a lot of like hidden location areas
they have noticing in this trailer why
[Music]
that's gonna be
workers
[Music]
that's gotta be on free right I mean you
would think yeah no that's Seattle I am
wondering how this movie's going to be
structured because we're bringing up how
the director said they're going for this
top going to vibe but the way the
trailer kind of communicates these
flashback moments they feel almost like
dream sequences in a way it's like one
thing where she's bonding with Maria but
then you got this like one shot where
she's on a rope and it's like she seems
like the captain marvel of how she's
being introduced kind of this where am i
and under trying to understand this were
like the way her face is reading it it
looks like it's a dream sequence or
she's like living and part of her
flashback in a way I don't know if you
guys know what I mean by that kind of a
pseudo where you have the character kind
of experiencing the flashback but in
yeah yeah just triggering you know
memory flash but I mean it's like they
insert the character yeah now into their
flashback yeah and especially the
structural format is reminding me a lot
of Man of Steel I know it's weird to
keep referencing it but she comes to
earth she's flashing back to her past
she's like this moment she's on the rope
she falls and then he reminds her of her
childhood yeah and then you cut to
another moment where she's in her pilot
outfit but it looks like she's landing
it is like yeah yeah he gets her read
before she gets her powers it looks like
I don't know if this is cool trailer
editing yeah in terms of like matching
the cuts with the Falls or if that is
the way her minds kind of working where
it's just in a bunch of different places
in her life at once well I'm thinking of
it as a trailer to this also makes me
wonder how much of the movie they're
they have to draw from at this point in
time to put into a trailer because this
does feel kind of contained yeah you
know as far as a Marvel trailer goes I
mean you definitely get some cosmic
stuff I liked that idea that we're gonna
go back and perhaps at least a little
bit to see her as a child because I
think that was one of my favorite things
about Man of Steel that first half stuff
where you kind of spend time in the
shoes yeah not just seeing how they
acquire their powers we touched on the
other video but that is Maria Rambo if
they're setting up clearly Monica
Rambeau whose spectrum in the comics and
they're saying that up for Phase five
and six is obviously we know
this film is set in the 90s basically
Monica Rambeau her daughter spectrum she
can transform into any form of energy
within an electric magnetic spectrum
spectrum also we see on the Jetta it's a
spot-on
John you know spot of that and obviously
that's one of her aliases in the comics
or daughter Monica but again they're
just setting up that whole dynamic and
cuz they do that in all the Marvel yeah
where they set up something you know
mentioned something like you see Bucky
with a lot of foreshadowing him holding
up the few little details like that so
they're clearly they're setting up
spectrum here you know the fact that
there's like one black supporting
character here really does resemble that
this is a 90s movie you know yeah you
know like everyone on earth is is white
and everyone on crease is why he did
then you got Sam Jackson to monitor yeah
[Music]
then they have that shot where like
she's going upside down and it's making
me wonder you know the new suit that
looks like the scarf or dreaming
lighting same time like what's her
memory white or does she just does she
just forget what's happened because of
all her experiences or was this the
experimental time well what's happening
to her when they're when she's getting
the DNA yeah yeah Houston her DNA my
guess would have to be that yes
something would happen to kind of remove
or or to hide those memories somewhere
to have her be like I keep having these
memories you know I can't man she would
have just forgotten but that's part of
the plot of the film she comes back to
her to rediscover you know herself yeah
you know know who she is origin and then
she goes screw this I'll see you guys in
2018
but I mean John did mention that there
was possible maybe hints of like the
time vortex or the quantum realm so
maybe that's why she doesn't age you
know when when we get to Avengers 4 cuz
I mean I'm assuming she looks exactly
like this and that gonna look too much
older when we get to Avengers force
I mean I don't know it was hard to tell
in this trailer if there was any hints
of quantum realm or time vortex or any
that stuff it's going to be interesting
maybe it's just that Kree DNA yeah rush
[Music]
we got Marbella we got Walter Lawson and
then if we go back can we go back a
little bit a shot of the other Star
Force members we don't get them all but
we got believe that's gamma chant from
crazy rich Asians
yeah and then she's playing Minerva to
the left over there is bran char and
then we got behind you can't really see
that's Atlas and I would imagine on the
left
yeah they show the pictures of course
and I mean I think in this image you're
actually gonna go see ronan based off of
the the photo is a TW released i think
in this specific and really quick just
star force they're basically they're an
elite cree member team you can I guess
yeah the way I like what's yeah I guess
I like to look at them as kind of like
you know the predator Dutch his team the
Mersenne yeah yeah I just want to get
into bleeds line you know we can kill it
I feel like this trailer and the e W
images because I know in some ways this
is also gonna be not an origin tale
eroded but a lot of backstory of what
leads up to him in his garden yeah in
Guardian something about the look on
Jude Law's face here tells me there's
some [ __ ] that's gonna go down in this
very specific scene with Rodin maybe
that's gonna be the pivotal point for
Ronan when he does something because at
this point he's fighting with the
Curie's with the crew yeah not a fanatic
yet yeah he's not but I'm wondering if
this is when the transition will begin
because does that look on Jude Law's
face speaks of like worry and horror or
could be you know Doctor Strange is
casting a spell and then they're all
looking at all the members of Sherlock
Holmes now they're all in the same Em's
yeah yeah no it's you're probably right
he's probably like there's some kind of
tension behind him and Ronin could be
over Carol Danvers like he's obviously
gonna have some kind of a relationship
with her well in the comics they have a
love like I think I'm gonna start off in
the origins right it was like a love
interest I've kind of surprised you
don't really get you long this trailer
since like they haven't been shy of
promoting him at all that he's in this
movie yet he's like barely get this one
shot yeah
you know you talked about the top gun
element here I feel like this children
does hint at that a little bit more than
I realized because they had these
flashes of her as a little girl I
dreaming of being a pilot I don't think
she's have been flying a real plane as a
little girl and then they cut to the
image of her as a pilot and then she's
probably you know flying spacecrafts and
all that it seems like being a pilot is
a real maverick part of her DNA a big
part of like her character we haven't
gotten that in in the MC fields we got
that a green Lancer
I don't know I mean not that's what
everybody's coming to see but honestly I
think that would be cool to have that
element come in too if they did some
actual you know aerial photography you
know made that a part of the DNA of the
visuals in this movie and stuff like
that you know they said she spent time
with actual pilots and I would love to
see that on the screen you know we're
spoiled by Mission Impossible and I
think that's a cue that they could
actually make pretty cool and effective
from there so and then she also of
commits elderly abuse in this trailer
yeah which is awesome because I think
it's about time we take down the old
people and what getting it away you know
like just cause they're old doesn't mean
we shouldn't hit them once in a while
regardless roll or not listen if any of
you guys work at a hospice center just
start punching them when they should
have and that's what captain Marvel's
I'm sure that's sure that's a scroll
Scott it's maybe she's a scroll and
that's gonna be like that's who she's
shooting at on the train Oh [ __ ] old
lady's getting away then we see ben
mendelsohn and this shot right before
that anything that's dad tell us right
on the beach yeah the beach right there
so that's Ben because I remembered I saw
an image of him in the e w one where he
looks like Brian Williams
he's like disguised as a human right I
don't know so again in the comics
Talos cannot shape-shift he can only
hand scroll you can only be in scroll
form but in this film they're changing a
little bit around from the comics he can
change into a human form rather and he
turns into Nick Fury's boss so I
mentioned in the other video I wouldn't
be shocked if he's the one that Nick
Fury mentioned in Captain America Winter
Soldier when he said Steve Rogers last
time I trusted someone I lost an eye he
can shape-shift into knickers boss at
shield so I wouldn't be shocked if this
is how I NIC be reduces his eye fizz
from him also I did read that when he's
in shape ship form as a scroll here or
rather when he's in squirrel form he's
got an Australian accent when he's
working for Nick Fury as she as his boss
he's got an American accent so that
throws off a lot of you know Nick Fury
was waiting to think you know that's
been Mouse and obviously doesn't look
like ben mendelsohn but just like his
voice like you don't you sound a lot
like my bow way you got an Australian
accent so that kind of throws it off
probably for him that's pretty neat
pretty cool we all get all these
comic-book movies or big films that he's
in at the Capitol most American uses
American accents they ask ok well then
in breaking down this trail a little bit
more I imagine that like who she's
actually tacking on that train must be a
like this has to be a stroll in disguise
right here course he would hope yeah
yeah might be like a fun looking
sequence if you like she's like chasing
after her when she's an old lady for me
and like trying to fight this what
people are thinking is an old lady and
she's going after her if she doesn't
morph in a scroll form but as I think
that'd be kind of a funny thing at 132 I
mean we thought we didn't see wrote it
in the trailer I mean I know I saw a
little shot yeah you get like a brief
tease that wrote it so fast I mean watch
the trailer twice yeah none of us notice
that that was Rotarian up but when you
really slow down this trailer you're
like oh there he is I don't know if
there if the scrolls are attacking earth
but at least having our invading or
they're evading for sure mm-hmm
is that what you read is Captain Marvel
showing up on earth to protect them
which is like easy why would they so
wait that's that's the plot point of
confuse are they chasing her that gets
earth now they're evading earth or they
evading or think you know marbles are
fighting I mean they didn't obviously go
into too much detail I just
read that the squirrels were invading
Earth there's the decree score war but
it just said that the squirrels were
invading Earth is okay clarify it will
probably get another plot point that'll
break it down more Phil Coulson doesn't
look very d aged yeah sure oh yeah no it
looks like very and again I love that
we're gonna get to see him in his rookie
year and he did mention an Iron Man -
that you know - mr. stark this isn't my
first rodeo maybe that's what he was
talking about so it's gonna be cool to
see the dynamic between him and Nick
Fury because again that's such a
meaningful relationship especially
everything that happens in the Avengers
I mean that's the whole main plot point
of that film is they're the ones he's
avenging it's tell Coulson so it's great
to see that he's back in the MCU of
course obviously we know he's an agents
of shield I just mean from the movie
sampling the music sighting it's great
to see him back again and I've heard
he's a big fan of MC Hammer in this it's
gonna be cool seeing 90s you know
stylized Phil Coulson and how that was I
hope the main bhi stories just a
bromance between him and Nick Fury and
then you do see the beeper here yeah
with some a target product placement
with tar gay targe targe I see I can't
tell if they cut the shop early and it's
supposed to say target or is target they
admire the MCU I'm not sure it might be
with target but or targer Targaryen
crossover the one thing I know is no one
on YouTube ever over analyzes things
never what kind of neighbors that I mean
where did he get the beeper I got a no
he's too fancy it's too modern-day basic
or underwater and they get the space
corner water kind of looks like Aquaman
meets Episode one but it's cool because
she's got the Masters she's got the
moment yeah from the comics when Carol
Danvers was first introduced she bore a
helmet you know and the color scheme
that resembled Marvel but the helmet
that she wore had a mohawk style you
know on top of the head on the helmet so
that's just like oh yondu yeah I just
want to know how much time it takes
Carol Danvers to slide her hair through
the slit and then hell
it seems like it would take a long time
and make this thing work out
speaking of eon do we obviously know
that he was a prisoner of the Kree it's
in the 90s so we know in the timeline he
picked up star-lord in 1988 so he's
probably off somewhere in space doing is
yeah I mean his Ravagers thing so I
don't expect to really see yondu in this
film that's how she the last time is
she's beating fenneis we don't get an
Avengers for obviously she's clearly in
her new supe I was gonna just one thing
I did want to mention really quick I was
thinking we are in the 90s now Asgard is
still around obviously because Thor
Ragnarok has not happened so you know
obviously when things happen on earth to
the point of the threat level is too
much for Humanity that's where Odin
intervenes so I wonder if the Asgardians
are even gonna be mentioned is like I
mean obviously we know that we're not
gonna see if they Hopkins or anything
like that but we're gonna feel any of
their presence in this because we know
the Asgardians are still around and they
do watch over everything I just kind of
thought about that that's one of the
more curious things to me about this
trailer because you do get very small
flashes of the further reaches of the
MCU yeah I wonder how much cuz this does
seem like from the footage we're getting
this is gonna be a pretty earth centric
movie right but I've also heard tons
about the potential of Captain Marvel to
broaden the spectrum of the MCU so I
wonder how much those things are gonna
figure it and maybe a second trailer how
much more we're gonna see from those I
just hope one thing though and I just
hope this film doesn't cause you know a
lot of continuity issues or problems
because I know a lot of people like to
go crazy over those but that's what
these universes you never run into that
problem ever never ever not like eight
years later in spider-man
as long as you're better than x-men to
me it was just right level of satisfying
it wasn't like oh my god I'm more hype
than I was before it's more like yeah
this is what I expect now from Marvel
this feels right in tune with my
expectations which is good it's not like
I got a low bar set I got a pretty every
Marvel movie I got a pretty high bar set
and they usually deliver my expectations
hidden I feel like it's gonna be another
case where I'm like yeah I imagine gonna
walk away going I really love that movie
yeah I mean look it's great to get hyped
up for a movie and if this trailer
didn't do it for you you know yeah what
it is and you move on to the next row
but it's still it's Marvel you know
Marvel hasn't really made too many bad
films toward the dark world but other
than that you know they really haven't I
mean they made just about every film
that I've seen has been very satisfying
to me personally I personally enjoyed
the trailer I get why some people had
issues with the trailer didn't find it
like oh my god I trust Marvel at this
point they've they burned my truck I'm
very curious to see this film there's a
lot of interesting elements I love that
we get to see Coulson and Nick Fury back
again in it and their dynamic and just
again getting to see - I want to see
ronan be fleshed out a little bit as
well I want to see who the most powerful
character that Kevin Feige described in
the MCU I also want to see - that bridge
between would tell if you've been doing
the last 20 years and what has happened
so it's all good I mean there's a lot of
curious stuff and intriguing things I
want to see her personality like this
trailer is a calculator and an a poised
introductory you know first impression
for this movie the the overall movie you
know this is cool because it's Marvel's
opportunity to break a new piece of
ground for their universe because you
know like DC kind of beat them to that
particular punch with Wonder Woman and I
like that this doesn't look like Wonder
Woman yeah it's like I'm with you guys
it's sort of like I like what I'm seeing
here it's on the level of what I've come
to expect from this movie and now I'm
just looking forward to seeing what the
actual personality of Carol is gonna be
like what the movies actual you know
unique qualities are gonna be like and
one last thing - oh I touch on is the
one of the writers of this film is
Nicole
and she wrote the first guardians of the
galaxy and I love the first guardians of
the galaxy I think it's a very
well-written film it's got a lot of
great tile logging into so I mean
rectify that pedophile right sure yeah
I'm just I'm talking about the writing
perspective from Nicole Perlman that's
all I was mentioning I just I trust
Nicole Perlman at this point and I mean
at least from that that films
perspective and I'm curious to see what
she does with this well I know I know
gun is very instrumental to that movie
but I'm coming on off that point I do
think the Guardians had a great balance
of like impactful kind of heavy
character moments with a lot of humor a
lot of sci-fi action a lot of like but
that movie does a particularly good job
of mixing all the things you would
hopefully want out of a waiter Marvel
movie so that gives me hope for this one
more thing I wonder who the scroll I
mean cuz I've been hearing but I'm
reading a lot that there could be a
scroll that's invade that's been here
the whole time throughout the entire MCU
up until this points like we're trying
to figure out it was but I know it is
it's Colonel James Rhodes look at that
acting change that happened from
Terrence Howard and Todd - Don Cheadle
it's clearly him it's Katie Holmes let
us know in the comments who you guys
think that scroll could be that really
is and that's possibly baby Avengers
maybe so our banner oh yeah there you go
Edward Norton and Mark Ruffalo there you
go yeah great I love it I was gonna say
I could see that - all right guys like
well say whatever you want in the
comments all right I'm gonna YouTube
question for you today I don't know how
to raise engagement you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation andrew is
alive and has a channel you should go
check it out patreon.com slash the real
rejects TV show reactions and q and A's
and follow us on the Stardust app if
you're one of the five people who
watched all the way to the end of this
video there it's free do it cuz free
things
are good things always true